so you're Elon Musk not today's Elon
Musk but 2001 Elon Musk you're around 30
years old and you no longer a child
prodigy anymore musk sold his first
computer program at the age of 12 and he
hasn't stopped selling since SpaceX
wasn't a thing tesla wasn't a thing and
you had a receding hairline that
magically went away you hit it big with
PayPal during the dot-com boom in
Silicon Valley and now you're left with
all this money lying around
now most people in the situation would
probably sit back and enjoy the fruits
of their labor as they think to
themselves of how they finally made it
but you're different you view money is
not the end game but a tool the startup
life in the place where you used to poll
23 hour workdays is starting to lose his
charm all people ever talked about was
funding IPOs how many hours they worked
the big paydays they were chasing and
you had a gut feeling that it was time
for a change that maybe you were meant
for more in life than just creating
internet services that maybe Silicon
Valley was just a stepping stone for you
so you decide to move to LA but not for
the glitz and glamour that most people
move therefore no no no no you
intentionally chose LA for very specific
logical reasons now that you're out of
the startup race with more money than
you could have ever wished for you've
had some time to ponder on life and to
revisit your childhood fantasies about
space travel and you decide that the
pursuit of space would be the start of
the next chapter of your life now you
don't know exactly what you want to do
in the space industry but you knew that
LA was one the main hotbed for aerospace
since the 20s because of its mild and
consistent weather whatever you decide
to do you'd be surrounded by the top
experts with a very large talent pool to
recruit from so la here we come although
you didn't know much about space or
rocket science at the time you quickly
made some well-connected friends who
didn't and the more you thought about
space the more you realize just how
important space exploration was for
Humanity what the next logical step of
colonizing Mars not just because
humanity will inevitably come to an end
if we're not on more than one planet but
because interplanetary exploration is so
intrinsically intertwined with the very
idea of America itself it's part of our
human spirit but here's the problem when
you visited NASA's website there was
literally nothing
no plan no schedule no nothing about
going to Mars NASA the agency
responsible for pushing the boundaries
of space wasn't just making slow
progress in the interplanetary travel
they had no intentions of it whatsoever
what happened to the Spirit we had for
the final frontier during the Apollo
days
you're obviously a pretty smart guy and
you come to the conclusion that
everything comes down to public supports
the general public holds the key to
everything you want in life if they
support what you want in this case space
travel the money the funding and the
supporters will follow if they don't
support what you want well you have the
American space efforts of the early
2000s during the Apollo days we had the
evil enemy of the Soviet Union we had to
be so rallying behind getting to the
moon was something that we could all
enthusiastically get behind we had
something to prove but today there's no
real perceived need or desire to go to
space how are you gonna change that so
you brought together a bunch of experts
and tasked them what tell me up with
some kind of grand spectacle that would
reinvigorate people's spirit and get to
Mars again but a budget of around 20
million dollars the first idea you were
throwing around was a sense of mice to
Mars have them return and May along the
journey
I ended up not being the most practical
idea ever so you guys settled on another
idea called the Mars Oasis you would buy
an old ICBM retrofitted to send a
robotic greenhouse to Mars the
greenhouse would then suck in Martian
soil and hopefully grow the first plants
on Mars with a video feed back to earth
still pretty ambitious but a lot more
practical than the mice to Mars idea so
it's time to go ICBM shopping even
though all your friends and family tried
to talk you out of your space ambitions
so you wouldn't waste all your money you
win a few friends hop on a flight to
Moscow this was during the post Soviet
Union days where the Russians were open
to bartering off stuff to rich guys
making it optimal for your Mars Oasis
mission when you met with the Russians
however they weren't too enthusiastic
about doing business with you and after
hours of frustrating preamble slightly
buzz from vodka you flower asks how much
of missile would cost eight million
dollars each you counter with two
missiles for eight million dollars they
were applied with something like young
boy no insinuating that you don't have
the money and you storm out of the
meeting the Russians were the only ones
that could possibly figure a twenty
million dollar budget so on the flight
you and your friends were understandably
disappointed you realize that if it cost
this much just for a decades-old ICBM
something that isn't even meant to
deliver stuff into orbit we will never
get to Mars at this rate but where
there's a problem there's a sweet
opportunity and you're not gonna let
this little hiccup stop you from your
life's calling then you have a stroke of
genius and pull out your laptop and
start typing your friends are thinking
nerd what could he be doing now a little
while later you turn around to your
friends with your laptop and say hey
guys I think we can build this rocket
ourselves aren't with a spreadsheet you
broke down the cost of the materials and
labor to build and launch a rocket for a
fraction of the price of the rusty old
Russian rockets what's more is that we
might even be able to build a profitable
business around it see the only
launching companies we're using giant
Rockets ascend giant payloads in space
but not everyone can afford these
expensive launches the military
scientists and private companies also
want to send smaller satellites into
space but the barrier for entry was just
too expensive for them to even consider
it this is where you come in by
undercutting the competition with
smaller cheaper rockets to serve an
entirely new customer base and if it's
profitable you can reinvest all your
profits into getting to Mars without
having to rely on government goodwill
that instead of wasting time when these
elaborate publicity schemes you can
revitalize people's interest in space
exploration by exploring space what we
do with SpaceX is to push the envelope
and provide a reason for people to be
excited and inspired to be human if the
Russians won't do it if the US won't do
it then it's up to you to turn
interplanetary travel into a reality and
SpaceX was born this is that story
[Applause]
the dawn of a new era of spaceflight is
upon us
[Music]
by June 2002 after studying rocket
science and the space industry for
months Space Exploration Technologies
was formed in an old warehouse in LA to
compete in an industry that had no
evolution in the past 50 years has
practically no real competition and
where all the rocket makers were
building Ferraris for every launch where
a Honda Civic might have made do so
here's how you approached it the goal of
SpaceX from a business standpoint was to
be the Southwest Airlines of space the
first rocket you would build would be
named the Falcon one after the
Millennium Falcon from Star Wars and to
get to this goal of affordability you
would bring your startup know-how of
being lean moving fast pivoting fast
with limited funds and applying it to
the space industry as full of the
slow-moving bureaucratic but he missed
like Lockheed and Boeing the initial
plan looked like this
most rocket builders had contractors
build out all the parts of 11 which led
to some hefty markups so you would build
your rockets nearly entirely from
scratch and then the goal was to
optimize the manufacturing assembly and
launch process so much that you can
launch faster and cheaper than the
others by orders of magnitude but the
real innovation came from the
realization that when we shipped things
by air sea or land we don't trash the
airplanes container ships and trailer
trucks after one use so if we can make
Rockets reusable like other
transportation vehicles we could have
multiple profitable launches per month
we could have the hope of getting to
Mars and we would never have to become
dependent on government contracts
but first we need to actually get a
privately built rocket into orbit before
we worry about landing it which proved
to be one of the more tougher
engineering hurdles of the 21st century
by the time word got out about SpaceX
almost everyone was thrilled but here's
the thing you want the first
entrepreneur to get into the space
industry and end up burning all your
money away the history is there and even
with eBay buying paper for a nice 1.5
billion dollars at the most you would
only be able to survive 3 or maybe 4
rocket launches to make Falcon one work
before going bankrupt how much of your
personal fortune have you poured into
this
100 million dollars a hundred million
dollars into something that you did not
believe would work at the beginning yes
even though you're a pretty smart guy
you're not gonna get anywhere anytime
soon without an all-star team in fact
finding the right talent is usually one
of the biggest bottlenecks for any
business if you want to attract talent
you have to be a company worth working
for
which is exactly what SpaceX was for the
first time in practically every young
overachievers with no lives fresh out
college your ideal employee didn't have
to join these giant bureaucratic
companies or government agencies if they
want to work in the space industry
SpaceX offered a breath of fresh air I
literally have walked into Boeing and I
said hey I could be an intern and they
lofted me and they said there's a whole
process that after birth through I went
there I serve any cold of a Elon and
Elon was like we could use the help
sure it sounds good it was a small
tight-knit family up against the world
so you have so much background in
engineering you could have easily gotten
a job at Boeing or at Lockheed but you
came here if you had a chance to go back
in time and work with Howard Hughes when
he was creating TWA if he had a chance
to be there at that moment when it was
the dawn of a brand-new era wouldn't you
want to do that I mean that's that's why
I'm here
but the real rite of passage came when
building the Falcon 1 this would be the
ultimate test the see of a syrup could
really go up against entire nation
states and win here's what the process
looked like you designed them build of
rockets in LA employees would then load
it onto a u-haul trailer and drive it
halfway across the country to your
testing site in Texas they'd worked
12-hour days and run the engines until
they broke or exploded which the
engineers called rapid unscheduled
disassemblies Texas would then let la
know what changes to make new parts
would then be shipped from LA to Texas
for testing to start all over again and
this would later be known as the Texas
cattle haul at the end of each day they
would report back to you if they were
working hard you'd be perfectly patient
when they ran into problems which is
practically every single day however if
they didn't have a plan of attack to
handle the roadblocks they ran into well
that is where you draw the line then
SpaceX Kaunas first customer the
Department of Defense for a satellite
launch that you aim for early 2004 a
very ambitious timeline what this goal
said 12-hour workday six days a week
became the norm what
working more than that fast for too long
years passed that early 2004 goal and
the Falcon 1 was finally ready for his
first test launch on March 24 2006 3 2 1
0+1 20 seconds into the launch and all's
well already a pretty impressive feat
for a start-up Falcon 1 is airborne at
this time by 25 seconds however a fire
started above the rocket engine and came
tumbling back down to earth
of course you're disappointed but you
remind yourself in the world that all
pass rockets have only had a few
successful launches out all their tests
the attempts so it's back to the drawing
board it took almost an entire year
before SpaceX will launch again on March
21st 2007 this one was much better with
five straight minutes of a perfect
rocket launch into space
[Music]
during separation is confirmed but then
it starts to wiggle and eventually blow
up a very respectable improvement over
the last one but we're not quite there
yet and what's worse is that the company
could only really last one and maybe two
more attempts before you ran out of
money so things are starting to get
pretty dire by 2008 space X was ready
for their third attempt four years after
their original goal of early 2004 and on
August 2nd 2008 the Falcon 1 launched
off left off was good all the engine
checks were good and everything was
going so well until a first stage
separate from the second stage and they
bumped into each other damaging the
first stage six years of 12 hour work
days and still nothing to show for it
this almost shattered the team but you
kept their spirits up while deep down
you knew that the fourth launch was the
make-or-break point for this company
SpaceX already had another rocket built
so launch 4 took place around two months
later on September 28 2008 employees
were trying not to throw up the fate of
your dream of interplanetary travel was
on the line and with every milestone the
rocket hit the team's cheers only grew
Esterly commissioned and with nearly ten
minutes into the journey the Falcon was
shut down its engines and became the
first private rocket to reach orbit and
that would be a nominal seeker which
means Falcon 1 has history as the first
privately developed launch vehicle to
reach Earth orbit from the ground
[Applause]
[Music]
so you finally proven yourself to the
world but you're not in the clear yet
the success of Falcon 1 was great bye it
was a very short-lived it was the end of
2008 and both Tesla and SpaceX were so
out of money that you had to borrow from
friends to make payroll the next two
SpaceX projects you already announced
the Falcon 9 a reusable rocket with nine
of the same engines from the Falcon 1
and the Dragon capsule designed to carry
cargo and astronauts would both need
around 1 billion dollars each to develop
when no money insights you went from
being a famous celebrity entrepreneur to
getting ripped apart in the media for
your recent divorce and Tesla problems
and to top it all off we were right at
the climax of the 2008 financial crisis
where Lehman Brothers going bankrupt
just two weeks before your successful
Falcon 1 launch and in your darkest
times ironically the very thing you
didn't want to become dependent on
government contracts came to your rescue
at the very last minutes when NASA
awarding SpaceX the contract for 12
resupply missions to the ISS for a
blissful 1.6 billion dollars and the
rest was relatively uphill climb from
there
since those dark days things have gone
as great as you could have ever hoped
for both Falcon 9 and Dragan sought out
setting success in 2010 Falcon 9
successfully landed back down to earth
in 2015 and your biggest rocket the date
Falcon Heavy had its first successful
flight back in 2018
[Applause]
fast forward to today and SpaceX heavily
undercuts all its competitors all around
the world the Falcon 9 is the main
workhorse for the company and have a
price tag of 60 million dollars per
launch it's cheaper for customer than
going to Europe Japan or even Russia and
China by a huge margin an even bigger
rocket named starship that's meant to go
to Mars and even offer transportation
around the globe is well underway
StarLink a giant web of satellites
beaming down internet to the hardest to
reach places around the globe
will hopefully act as the cash cow
needed to fund more Mars planning the
global satellite industry just keeps
getting bigger and bigger every year
with the largest numbers at nearly 300
billion dollars in 2018 and although we
can't tell how profitable SpaceX is
being neither a private company it's
safe to say that they're in a pretty
good spots but perhaps most importantly
you've single-handedly inspired a new
generation of people excited to explore
the final frontier
with more space startups today than ever
and it all started with the original
plan to fly some mice to Mars on a
soviet-era
ICBM but space X's biggest milestone
might be just around the corner nine
years ago the u.s. retired the space
shuttle program and since then America
has had to rely on their old enemy
Russia to fly to space but at the time
of recording this video that is set to
change on May 27th with space X's first
ever human crew planned to launch up to
the ISS which could be delayed by the
time you're watching this video we just
checked the news the two astronauts Doug
Hurley and Bob Behnken will be flying up
in their new crew Dragon capsule
retrofitted for astronauts with
touchscreen displays cool seats that
minimalist aesthetic Tesla and SpaceX
are known for and of course very
futuristic looking pressurized suits if
this mission they're calling demo two is
successful SpaceX will have played a key
role in bringing NASA's human space
program back to US soil and after 18
long years nearly two decades and many
more years leading up to that grinding
away to have enough money to start space
X in the first place you've come back
full circle to your childhood days of
fantasizing about space travel except
now it's one step closer to becoming
reality but here's the thing it's easy
to look back on the stuff and say just
how obvious reusable rockets were how
obvious it was that our planet is in the
center of the solar system or how yes
there
absolutely these strange invisible waves
that we can't see with the naked eye
that we can use to communicate quit
being silly
it's easy to look back at history and
rationalize these things but
statistically you probably would have
been one of those haters putting down
Elon Musk if you were a part of the
Roman Inquisition you probably would
have supported throwing Galileo in
prison for saying that the Sun is the
center of the solar system not our
planet such hearsay right thrown in the
gulag and I wouldn't be surprised if you
or I are acting like this right now
about things people are working on today
that are supposedly impossible so I just
want to end this video with a gentle
reminder to keep an open mind to what's
possible and to remind you that the
future is up for grabs
[Music]
welcome to the watch that end Club and
if you are still watching right now with
like 18 straight minutes into the video
you guys are my biggest supporters so
thank you so much and if you guys want
more like mini-documentaries like this
just let me know in the comments because
I can't do these like all the time
because they take like a really really
long time but I can try my best to
squeeze it in here and there if you guys
want it if you guys don't want more mini
documentaries like this that's okay just
put a comment below and just put I
watched the very end to give that
YouTube algorithm a nice little boost if
you're new to this channel please
consider subscribing because I make
video essays just like this one every
single week on the most provocative
stuff in the world of business for
absolutely nothing if you want to
support this channel financially one of
the best ways to do so is what the Tran
mafia family also known as patreon you
can start as an associate a soldier or
go all the way in and start as capo and
support this channel of making the world
a more curious place you can follow me
on instagram at jake trend io that is
gonna wrap it up for this very long
video thank you so much for watching
again you guys you an awesome
I've been Jake I'll see you guys in the
next one
[Music]